[Applause]
agent infiltrate the compound and
retrieve the water filtration unit and
watch your back it might be
[Music]
wow
hello everyone welcome to geek squad
geek culture's resident cave of all
things gaming
zeki here alongside with us is jake our
dedicated trophy hunter jake say hello
what's up everyone this is jake i like
trophies i like hunting i play on a ps4
that's all you need to know
and today we will be bringing you some
of the action in the division 2 episode
1 dc outskirts dlc
as you can see from our introduction
video there's a crocodile involved so
you can expect things to get real
exciting
and as a division noob myself tell me on
why i should jump into the division
right now jake right assuming you played
the division one yes yes i did and uh
loved it and i hated it yeah tell me
what did you hate about it i just felt
the the game was broken i mean i bought
it when it launched i had the steel
bookcase and everything like that
i had the shirt
uh i really enjoyed the story but
i kind of stopped playing for a week and
then i just realized everybody got
stronger than me and i you know and
it was all about the dark zone getting
the loot and things like that too
as i felt that was the progression for
me
but the rates just got very hard and
glitches start coming out
you know people were just trying to get
through the
the glitches and yeah the game just
didn't promise
the things i wanted in that game much
like anthem
oh
[Music]
yeah so basically the division two it's
everything that was at the end of
division one
everything all the expansions or the
fixes whatever you know updates that
develops can could do
times a thousand
so it's basically the best division that
you can
have right now
and it's probably one of the best cover
based shooters that has ever been made
that's that's actually
strong praise
yeah considering yeah you mentioned
anthem right so
the launch of the division two has been
nothing but
spectacularly perfect you know right
there's no server issues you know you do
get the occasional glitches and bugs but
they're so
they happen so infrequently that it
really really doesn't matter and on top
of that the gameplay that the gun play
has been refined
so intricately you know the cover based
shooter the system is perfected enemies
no longer feel bullet spongy you know
you
you are in danger as much as them so
there's a strategic
trade-off there you know you can have
really really good gun play and action
and set pieces
and all in all it's a really really
great time whether you're playing solo
or together in the team of four
right if you didn't already know episode
one is but one of the many free updates
to the game
and as you can see uh maybe jake you can
explain what's happening now
yeah so basically this is uh
one of the new main missions that has
been added as part of episode one
basically if you are looking at this
mission right now spoiler alert
[Applause]
you better finish the main story first
so this is the manning national zoo
where the division has been sent in out
of washington dc the city proper we are
now at the zoo to hunt the leader of the
outcast who is otherwise known as
emeline shaw who
you know if you played the main game the
story you realize that
even when we took down the outcast
stronghold we didn't actually manage to
eliminate emilyn shaw so right now we're
here in the zoo trying to hunt her down
as you mentioned before i know that
there are a lot of things that's new to
not only the division 2 but the dlc as
well so maybe you can actually tell us
what's new about this episode yeah so
episode 1 adds in two new missions that
flashes out the story even more so like
i said this is the manning national zoo
and then there's the other one cam white
oat where you go and hunt down the rogue
vice president of the united states
that is uh we'll leave there for another
video which will you know be slowly up
uploading our adventures in episode one
there's also uh classified assignments
as well as a new discovery difficulty
for operation dark hours which is the
rate
as well as the new pva experience
expedition
all right so that sounds really enticing
and the division 2 is a game we should
definitely definitely have in our
wishlist at least in my wish list
you know
safe to say there will be more updates
coming up right
and uh yeah i think it's something worth
jumping into now or even later when
there's a sale of course oh i would
definitely recommend you jump in now
just in case you feel left out and you
know there are players around they can
help your power level and stuff like
that
and just a little bit more about the
information about this
dlc it's episode one dc outskirts
it is one of the first of the three new
dlc episodes that will be coming out
from now till
early 2020.
with that being said episode 2 pentagon
the last castle was slated for fall 2019
and episode 3 coney island homecoming to
be out in early 2020 so you can find a
division two year one roadmap in the
description below
yeah
the game seems pretty fast paced and
there's a lot of action going on
and
from what i experienced in division one
it's just the enemies are super
challenging even on normal
so maybe you can kind of explain
how does this cater to everyday gamers
or casual gamers like myself i wouldn't
say the division 2 is too high there's a
certain degree of challenge
but uh
like most of uh this kind of shooters
you need to be geared properly don't be
taking on things that are too way high
level for you
and then i think you'll be fine anyone
that can pull a trigger and aim i think
you'll be fine playing the division too
but yeah yeah just just check this out
yeah weird fish that never die
yeah so
if you stay in cover you pick you pick
your time
to come off cover take a few port shots
you should definitely
be dying less than you would expect to
especially considering division one
as as the game was updated towards the
end i think it felt more balanced and i
think the vision 2 is much
it's even more balanced than before
and the enemies are well designed the
factions are varied they all have
different functions they come at you
differently and i think as a division
agent you have even more tools at your
disposal to take care of
the different
threats that are coming your way from
the enemy factions
ubisoft has really done a good job in
terms of
how enemies are portrayed in this sense
i mean there's bound to be bullet
sponges but it's not everywhere
in a sense yes like there are hardier
enemies you know not your regular grunts
that you can take down in a few bullets
to hit there are heavies which are these
big hawking guys that have armor plates
around their body
so it's more of picking your spot in the
sense if you
consistently shoot at a certain area of
his body the armor will break off
you you can target his flesh and take
down his health really really quick
that similarly you as a division agent
you are not invincible as well if you
are not in cover you are always always
in the open yeah the enemies can review
the threats as well
every faction has their different quirks
like i mentioned the outcasts we are
looking at right now
for example they are snipers uh ball
wielding
you know robin hoods who can you know
snipe you from afar with explosive
arrows and they are the only faction
that has uh suicide bombers as well
yep and then they're heavy can usually
either be carrying like a flamethrower
or they'll chase you down like crazy
giant man with sledgehammers that forces
you to mix up your strategy that you
can't always hide in cover and be safe
forever
i think i think that's why i'm so drawn
to this game because it's not something
where they would dumb it down for you
and you know all just running gun just
clear enemies like you got to be smart
and really fully utilize that cover
system that's given to you of course you
can just play the game you know a cover
cover shooter or you know just a running
gun shooter if you if you prefer to play
it that way whether you survive or not
is another question okay yeah and then
out in the world um
just look at those arrows those are very
very annoying arrows yeah so even in the
open wall there are like puzzles to
solve there are
secrets to find
so that there's actually plenty of
gameplay elements outside of the
shooting that they can keep players
engaged and you know learning more about
this world that they have built
um
so as we can see we are
now fighting the outcasts in order to
get to the leader right yep and
what are the other factions like
involved in and what do they bring to
the table yeah so the other three
factions too uh in the main game which
are the true sons
and uh which is uh like a military
faction ex-soldiers that have turned
crazy somehow and then you have the
hyenas who are
basically just anarchists who just want
to see the world burn
if you completed the story then the main
story and
of the division two you'll meet the
black tusks
who are
technologically advanced and they're
almost like the opposite of division
agents
just that you know they are not on the
side of good they are on the side of evo
yeah so all these factions they have
their own
uh teams that the true sons are all
about shotgun they have foam canisters
that can trap you you know force you out
into the open and then you have the the
hyenas who will rush you they take drugs
and then they go crazy and they run
after you with batons
sounds like the reapers from
days gone yeah actually i would say the
outcasts are more like the rippers with
their bald head and all you know crazy
tattoos right yeah and then you have the
black tusks who uh they can use
technology can you they they have drones
and they can they have robot dogs they
have
robotic tanks
that can just take you out at instant
with sniper rifles and stuff like that
so it's all different challenges and
then you have to approach its uh each
situation differently and
how you decide to take the fight to the
enemies and who to prioritize all this
comes into play it's always a fun time
and a refreshing time no matter who you
are facing in the game
interesting
so as you can see outside of this main
mission we also have cam white oak in a
later video
and in addition there are more
classified assignments maybe you can
explain more about those yeah so they
recently added a few classified
assignments and in episode 1 there will
be two more being added the central
aquarium and
nsa site b13 basically these optional
and shorter missions like maybe 10 10
minutes or so that take place outside in
the world around washington dc
so it helps build up the law and world
building of the division two a look and
those are the crocodiles that we're
talking about
yeah they're really really really really
fast
usually fast yeah and then you know
those are
those help you know add a little bit
flavor to the world division too and
especially if you're looking for
collectibles each
division 2 classified assignment has
about four audio logs those are the
radio transmissions that you can listen
to learn more about the story and what
happened to the people at these specific
locations
along with a backpack trophy
and one of those uh if you take a look
at my backpack right now you can see a
very cute little hot dog hanging out
yeah those are backpack trophies yeah
and i think it's great for collectible
hunters as well you want to have full
set or whatever you want to be the best
you want to collect everything there is
then it's best that you you can take
part in all these classified assignments
even more more ways to have fun in the
division two
so jake there's also the much discussed
difficulty being added to operation dark
hours what are your thoughts on that
yeah so basically operation dark hours
is the raid which was just recently
added by the development team
at the start there were a lot of
complaints that console players couldn't
really complete the raid while pc gamers
were doing it in less than 20 minutes
which is really really the difference
between console players and pc players
was really really big but right now they
have added discovery difficulty
which is
i'll say a much more forgiving
difficulty for players to
go to you know get together a team of
well-drilled and
purposely built
team to tackle the raid you can match
make with other people they are also
trying to experience the rate for the
first time
and
you can do the same thing as the normal
rate just that
you get lesser rewards
and i think it's a good way to introduce
people to what the red can offer in
terms of the puzzle solving the enemies
even though they are at a lower
difficulty i'm hoping that it will wet
the appetite of all these new players or
those that were
daunted by the difficulty of the raid
and how do i say more encouraged to you
know try to build towards having a real
beaut
maybe have more
thought put into
their building up their gear their
weapon their talents in order to be
raped really so i think that's a good
thing overall so people can stop
complaining about not being able to
access sound with content yeah
especially when
the team has
previously made statements that all the
activities and the division two will
have matchmaking so i think they are
trying to leave up to the bargain at the
same time not
lowering down the rewards that people
should get if they play the normal rate
would you actually say it's like a warm
up or like some you know building up
your your gear score or your even your
builds like it's kind of a
testing ground to see whether you're up
to
the enemy's level personally not try the
discovery difficulty yet uh as i've been
running the normal rate myself so i
think
regardless of whether you get uh
you're getting good drops from discovery
it doesn't really matter until you get
into the normal rate and see how your
weapons stack up against the enemy and
how hard they can actually hit you which
is really really hard sometimes
yeah so
like i mentioned i think it's just
giving people a taste of what they are
missing out if you know
if they actually want to put time in you
know inspect your builds and perfect
your your formula and then and try to
tackle rate with a team of you know
seven other like-minded individuals
so that you can have a great time trying
to clear the rate
so
uh at the end of the day you know more
people playing it's always a good thing
more people getting the experience stuff
is always a good thing so hopefully we
have more people completing the raid and
discovery will hopefully help them
achieve that
you guys listening to us you guys seen
the video this is one huge ass zoo
and it certainly feels bigger than what
we have here in singapore obviously
and the environments all look varied and
you know it just
it just has
yeah definitely you know you remember in
division one you're stuck in the city
it's always snowy
it's always dark you know you're going
on to even darker places underground and
in the metro and also in the division
too everything
it's basically more colorful as you can
see you know just not in it not just in
this mission but overall in the entire
story you know the entire progression
you have throughout the game you're
visiting different locations you have to
go from buildings you know to parks to
even the underground looks much more
pleasing to the eye than what we are
used to so there's a there's a very big
improvement compared to the first game
i also see that right now
the armor has points as well yeah so now
instead of mad kids you're using armor
kits so like
the heavy enemies you have a set amount
of armor that you can have before you
start taking damage to your health
so it's much like you know the the
health kits in division one but i think
it makes more sense you know to have
armor protecting your health
instead of having just a super long
health bar that you know that feels
different every time you get shot at
and we just saw about the revive system
as well yeah there's one of uh that's
the revival hive in action yeah so the
division two also added a few other
tools you know new gadgets for players
the returning ones are like the the
turret now there's drones
other than you know the familiar ones
like seeker mines and such so yeah i'm
not really a gadget guy by playing solo
i think it's very important to have the
revival hive and you know the cam
launcher to heal yourself the developers
are definitely trying to make it more
viable to have skill based builds
so that's something positive to look
look towards to as well so as you
mentioned i myself am
more of a
sport
so
what can you tell us more about ubisoft
trying to
really blend in all different kinds of
players in terms of skill set or their
preference in play so what can you tell
us more about
specialization of classes yeah i think
the main difference in division two is
uh the specialization system like you
mentioned so there are three and now
with the new gunner specialization four
specializations that players can as long
as you return to the base of operations
you can change your specialization
so there's the gunner which i'm running
now who is uh carrying a huge minigun
and then you have the demolitionist who
is armed with a grenade launcher
a survivalist with a crossbow and then
finally the sharpshooter with a really
really big ass sniper rifle so those are
the archetypes that you can
choose to play with you know you want to
stay at the back and pick off enemies
from afar go for the sharpshooter you
know if you like to
get up close and personal you know doing
some aoe damage the grenade launcher for
the demolitionist is for you
and like you said you've got a support
class there's uh the survivalist who
carries a
crossbow which can be
explosive you know and his other skills
are more
pointed towards supporting the the rest
of your party members the the new gunner
you get like
you can't get into cover with a huge ass
minigun but you know you get added armor
you get better reload
and recently they just we hauled the
specialization
point system
so previously
each of the specialization they only
they could add bonuses to damage and
handling and other stuff like that to
certain weapons but now in all four
specializations you can choose which
weapons you want to add all these
bonuses to which is another good thing
for players
to
specialize how they want to and in the
way they want to play so that's only a
good thing and in addition to that i
think the developers have been doing a
really really good job of supporting the
game
yeah in addition to
what we mentioned task far
title update five which uh dropped
together with episode one uh will add
new exotics which are you know the super
strong weapons and gear to the game and
then they'll be working on gear
balancing adding new weapons improving
crafting and like i mentioned they're
trying to make skill builds more viable
like for example right now the raid
build it's all about dps without dps
yeah pretty much a goner yeah but right
now they're trying to make skill builds
but also players like yourself if you
want to go support you know not always
take part in action it's a possible way
to play and more importantly they
recently added a flashlight attachment
that you have to find though uh in the
in the game for your sidearm as people
has been complaining about how dark the
the tunnels are and stuff like that so i
think you know they are listening to
fans which is always a good thing and
they are doing their best to make the
division to uh even better game
which is actually
a bit different right because usually
most of the weapon mods now
are
unlocked by
uh progression rather than a new thing
right
yes and no i guess you can find
blueprints out in the world uh there are
certain missions that reward you with
blueprints
you know there are projects to complete
it's a balance between going out finding
the right one hope and sometimes you're
just hoping for drops it's much better
than the first game but sometimes it's
still a
crap shoot really so of course what you
guys are watching now is just the tip of
the iceberg that is episode 1 and
tu5 but there's more to look out for
right yep uh we'll definitely be
taking everyone through the other main
mission which is a camp wide open as
well as the brand new pv experience uh
that is called expeditions
i mean they seem
they still sound like side missions but
maybe
yeah so just like the this
manning national zoo and uh cam widow
they take place outside of washington dc
this uh the expeditions are new pv
events that unfold in multiple stages
so players will get to head to each
investigation area which is called a
wing
then you can explore you can fight and
of course search for even more
collectibles
and there will be three wings that will
progressively be unlocked each week
i think this is week number two so you
have even more wings to
explore now and if you complete them all
at the end you'll unlock a treasure room
full of loot which is what everyone is
chasing
and if you
finish this particular expedition that
they added in episode 1
you will have the division 2 diamondback
exotic rifle that will be awaiting you
not really you know you level up really
fast you know you get gear almost
every every time you know it might not
be the gear you're looking for
but
i can say you know the grind from level
1 to 30 is very very enjoyable
but and once you get past the end you
get into the end game where you're
trying to up your gear score to right
now the cap which is 500
even if you're not at max 500 if you
have really good
talents that work with each other you
know it doesn't really matter your gear
score as long as you're above above 490.
i think you can have a great time but
like i said if you're trying to look for
the perfect blend of gear
weapons mods
it's gonna take some time yeah
but hopefully the enjoyable parts make
it much easier for you to get past that
and
how many hours
the last i checked i'm about
160 hours
so yeah it is pretty fast
yeah considering you know i played the
entire game solo all the way until you
know the raid forced me to you know find
a group of other other players
yeah so whether you're playing alone or
together with friends
which i actually highly recommend you
play with friends you can experience
everything together you can talk and
party the division 2
it's
challenging enough
but most importantly very very enjoyable
to play through beat the story the
gameplay the exploration i think they
did a really really good job of
realizing washington dc as a
gameplay world
and ultimately i think it's all about
you know having fun
fighting enemies you know
taking on a challenge of one person
against many many foes and
having badass weapons you know to go
along with it
you know as long as it gets the job done
even a water pistol would do or you know
pet crocodile you have seen like the one
that we have in our pool yeah
and no it just it just looks
very impressive from
what i've seen in the previous games i
think this is a big step up
and i really can't wait to try it and
get my hands on it
and i think it's recommended that
everybody should at least give this game
a second shot
or a second chance it's definitely in
our list of the top games of 2019 and
probably my top pick for
game of the year as of now well yeah
we're still early but
if you're talking about game that has
helped my attention
for a long period of time and not
making me get bored of its mechanics
it's
and how much i enjoy it just every day
logging and doing the things that i want
to do shoot some fools in the face
grab some stuff
it's really really good it's really fun
and i think it's
approachable enough for new players but
also challenging enough for
veterans of cover shooters or just
shooters in general
and and with the amount of support the
game is getting i think
there's no better life service games out
there right now
compared to
the disastrous anthem i think i think
destiny 2 is another one that is slowly
getting back on its feet yeah yep so
right now the division 2 is probably the
best shadow shooter out there
but i understand if you know the modern
day shooter isn't your cup of tea but
for anyone who
who thinks that they might be interested
definitely give it a try
well folks thanks for staying tuned
we've got more division 2 content for
you guys on geek squad coming up we're
gonna let you guys enjoy the rest of the
video as jake
demolishes the rest of the outcasts at
the national zoo along with the boss
fight emeline shaw amelie and shaw and
yeah with that uh please
hit that subscribe button as well as
that notification bell icon so you can
stay up to date with our latest geeky
content and news let us know in the
comments below about what you like and
what you didn't like about the division
2 or what you would like to see more of
until then stay geeky
division 2.
come on
serious trauma
medical assistants needed
make me
see how the mama bear has watched us
she's making sure we aren't going to try
to hurt her baby
that's what mothers do
target deceased
what a [__] waste
think of the good she could have done
the lives she could have saved she was
right you know
killing her won't end the outcasts it
might even make them more dangerous for
a while
but without her to hold them together
they're gonna start to unravel
what a [__] waste
you